Kids -- love 'em or hate 'em,
you can't deny the fact
that they're young.
Recently...
[ Laughter ]
Recently I had a chance
to talk to some kids
for a new original
television segment that I call
"Children Say Things You Don't
Expect Them to Say Sometimes."
♪♪
Do you know any jokes?
Knock, knock.
Who's there?
Ach.
Ach who?
[Achoo]
Bless you.
Ahh!
I'ma give you a half quote,
and then I need you
to finish it.
Okay.
You better check yourself
before you...
Go on a date.
[ Laughs ]
What's your favorite
Taylor Swift song?
Um...
"The Twinkle, Twinkle
Little Stars."
That must be an album cut.
Have you seen
my stand-up comedy before?
No.
You look familiar, though.
Yeah?
I think you kind of
look like a Tyler Perry.
What's your favorite
TV show?
"Zig & Sharko."
It's on Netflix.
On Netflix?
Do your parents put the Netflix
kids' filter on yours
so you can't watch
9/11 documentaries?
-Knock, knock.
-Who's there?
-Ach.
-Ach who?
[ Chuckles ]
Okay....
Who's your favorite
basketball player?
Mike Dunleavy?
-I don't know.
-Mike Dunleavy?
-Yeah.
-Yeah?
Can you look in the camera
and say,
"Mike Dunleavy
is better than Michael Jordan"?
Mike Dunleavy
is better than Jordan.
You heard it here first.
You better check yourself
before you...
Riggity wreck yourself.
Okay.
Wait,
why do you know that?
The only thing to fear is...
Um, when, um...
people try
to take you away.
That's a pretty --
That's a pretty solid fear.
I think your quote
might be more impactful
than the originator's.
Can I try a joke?
-Okay.
-Cool.
So, I go back home to Chicago,
and my dad says,
"Hey, you ever
hear of this show 'The Wire'?"
And I'm like, "My dad just
found out about 'The Wire.'"
He's like, "Yeah,
season two of 'The Wire'."
Who am I to judge my dad
for just now finding out
about the "The Wire"
when I found out
about Jimi Hendrix
because Hulk Hogan was using him
as his intro music?
Hulk Hogan
would walk out like
[Mimics guitar]
playing "Voodoo Child,"
and I'm like,
"Wow, this Jimi Hendrix guy
has got a huge future
for himself.
It's so cool of Hulk Hogan
to give him some exposure."
If you could be any age,
what age would you be?
The age I am now.
How old do you think I am?
42?
Perfect.
She got it right?
On the dot?
No, not right at all.
But it's better
than being called Tyler Perry.
I guess black
does crack.
I don't get it.